[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
happy Tuesday happy Tuesday it's great
to be back did you miss me huh yeah
well you know who I missed more
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate
Canada 2023
week 51.
the resurrection
[Applause]
oh yeah man this is awesome you thought
this Saga and the sagging was over sorry
gazumba gate it's back our coverage of a
teacher so busty that he needed three
mirrors to see his own feet
when this large boobed creature laid
down people thought a camel died
mushrooms started growing in their shade
here's a trip down mammary Lane
she was once a he began identifying as
female last year and started wearing
massive prosthetic breasts to class the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice in the unlikely
event of a water emergency landing your
shop teacher can be used as a flotation
device the shop teacher was recently
pictured in all her immense boobery
skydiving this story is getting bigger
and bouncier I made it go to my grave
never knowing the real story behind
those Titanic
but I'd rather die seeking the truth and
live in the shadows God he is gorgeous
over time so Kayla Kayla's back but it's
not the old Kayla we came to know and
love it's a new one a male one
ah you know what I'm thinking the old
one the real one is back and so the
students at Nora Francis Henderson's
Secondary School in Hamilton Ontario can
you get a longer name please
they just got their first lesson in
gender idiocy taught by the man himself
Carrie Luke and the lesson is this that
in order to expose bad ideas like gender
belief sometimes you have to amplify
them to the point of absurdity last week
Tyrus reported the Canadian teacher AKA
K-Cup had transferred schools well today
was the start of the new school year at
Kayla's new school he arrived he arrived
with a police escort and without the
gigantic prosthetics
he also donned a five o'clock shadow
but despite this the media still keeps
calling him
she
but we won't
a five o'clock shadow at eight in the
morning
you're not getting that from a chick
unless you're having breakfast with Joy
Behar
[Applause]
so despite Kayla's denials all the signs
point to the fact that Kayla was always
a man named Carrie all along and we knew
that when we heard he could parallel
park
Texas would say
but we always knew there was something
more to this than a case of
gigantomastia
I had that once but not there
it's funny the New York Times got
pulitzers for being dead wrong on the
Russian collusion hoax
and we nailed this story from the get-go
and kept on it for a year and I don't
even get an NBR tote bag
but I hate to say I told you so actually
I love saying I told you so it's my new
favorite thing to say after I'm here for
my prostate exam
if I've been right then this was the
greatest Punk since I promised the staff
a Christmas bonus
I gave them all copies of killmead's
last book
as you know I've been watching this
teacher closely with a lot of skepticism
and hand cream
don't judge
meanwhile the Canadian government was
too stupid and too terrified by the
progressive scolds to notice the obvious
that Carrie was running a long Con on
everybody this was one prank that wasn't
a bust
so what's his point or should I say
points
[Music]
possibly to show just how ridiculous
pronouns and gender as belief ideology
have become have you noticed by the way
that an obsession with jumping between
genders isn't quite as prominent in the
rest of the world you know where people
worry more about staying alive in lots
of countries Kayla would be ridiculed
for making children hopeful that they'd
get milk
action
through this it's not even prominent in
most of Canada they got real problems
like the creepiest prime minister on
Earth
once again I want you to look closely at
that picture it's not just the black
face that's disturbing what's with the
tongue on his right your left
who whose tongue does that belong to
could it be carries
as in Carrie the teacher not John Kerry
but the fact is an interest in
transitioning up there is about as
common as a full set of teeth on a
goalie
and in America same here the only people
interested are the dumb the easily
scared the easily tricked and Adolescent
suckers for attention as well as their
virtue signaling parents and our
universities in media and Hollywood the
land of vapid virtue signaling scum
nothing restores waning self-worth like
accessorizing yourself with children you
pump full of hormones and idiotic
beliefs it's this decades adopting
African orphans
so your agent's not calling you anymore
The Season's big charity events are
going on without you we'll buy your
eight-year-old son a low-cut dress and a
parrot
yeah
now do I know that uh this is Lemieux
point I don't neither version of him
will call us back
I feel like I'm in high school again
trying to get a prom date
he won't pick up and it's possible that
his new school uh actually had laid down
the law and told him he had to leave the
fake body parts behind but whatever his
motivation his disappearing inflatable
boobs showed the world how many real
boobs there are in government and in
schools
this might have been the greatest
ongoing parody since the bit presidency
yeah
he is
let's welcome tonight yes oh excuse me
she was my fixation when she hosted
alternative Nation host of Kennedy Saves
the World podcast Kennedy
he made his bones killing terrorists
with drones Fox News contributor Brad
balakovich
sees like a cool ball day slightly
chilly and covered in Dead Leaves and
frost New York Times best-selling author
in Fox News contributor Kat Tiff
[Applause]
and finally the Earth orbits him New
York Times best-selling author comedian
former NWA world champion Tyrese
Kennedy I don't think the world revolves
around me but is it possible is it
possible that this guy was doing this
all for me
if you think about it if you think about
it this has been going on wow I know so
many things make so much sense I'm
serious I'm not joking I'm actually good
with it yeah exactly what do you say
young lady I mean
I mean or absolutely yes that this is
all a very cleverly executed route
to make you feel a little Buzzy where
your bathing suit covers perhaps that
that was the the point of the whole
thing and guess what uh kudos to Kayla
because it worked but this this person
and I don't know I don't know which
pronoun to use at this point
what to make of it but this person told
the New York Post which is owned by our
parent company thank you New York Post
uh that they were intersex not
transgendered and also suffered from
that condition that you spoke of and
this was completely real and because of
that you know this this slovenly circus
freed frictum was a condition that
rendered that a victim yes and wanted
people to believe that so so became
ensconced In This Very intricate lie
that was all absolute garbage which just
speaks to a you know an untreated mental
illness or a sociopathy that means that
this person should not be around
children and should certainly not be in
school okay this is a very interesting
point and I really really hadn't
occurred to me but it always comes up
because I always forget about it Brett
what if it's not a long con it's a
mental illness I still say it's a long
con but Kennedy among other people
believes believe it's a mental illness I
think it could be a little bit of both
but either way this topic makes me feel
extremely uncomfortable every time I'm
here have you done this too well and by
the way the last time I was here we had
the same exact topic I don't know if you
guys think I'm like a subject matter
expert on trans or or what's the deal no
it's just that the topic comes up a lot
no listen look what bothers me the most
about this mental illness or not long
con or not is that you know the
educational department at this school is
putting this individual's needs over
that of the children right so I mean
what are we even doing that it makes no
sense it's absurd and you know look
there probably is a mental illness here
but uh you know at the same time like
you know this person was adamantly
claiming before that this chest or
whatever you know was real and they're a
proven liar because there were photos
that that showed they were in fact real
you know when they they photographed
this a while back before so like why
would you want this person dealing with
our children a proven liar forget about
the trans stuff for a second yeah it
happens when there's a bomb threat do
they have to shut down the school and
shelter in place every time some angry
person calls in a bomb threat because of
this yeah that's true that's true it's a
good point you're you're using logic
against somebody that is obsessed with
this story by the way
just to point out Brett you are on here
because the name Brett is non-binary so
you could you could I I and we didn't
ask I didn't ask that makes sense yeah
you're a good looking man but you're a
better looking lesbian
that was terrible cat are you hoping
that this is the final chapter in what
has been an extraordinary and
emotionally moving story
we were hoping it was the Final Chapter
when you weren't here last week
that's why Tyrus covered it is because
we were like we're gonna take it from
him yes I knew that's the strategy you
were doing well because I said so out
loud on the show I went too far yeah I
did I said I'm so glad we're doing this
so that we never have to do it again
because we just did a segment about it
we're like whereas Gutfeld would
probably do a whole monologue about it
and then I'd have to sit here and try to
think of something new to say because
you've you've been here twice I got
nothing left to say about this other
than you know obviously she was a woman
before now she's a man happens all the
time no it doesn't happen all the time
it doesn't happen all the time which is
why it's there's a lot of people who are
trans you just want to live their lives
yeah and then there's this who's you
know I mean Avi the amount of weird lies
like that those boobs are real that
still doesn't mean you can't cover the
nipples even if they were exactly right
exactly this okay but okay so this is
why Tyrus there is a new wrinkle to this
story you're gonna love this
yo you're gonna love this the
insistence that even the New York posts
refers to him as a she even after this
are you guys such cowards
[Applause]
can't you do it
what a bunch of
sorry
so angry I'm so angry over this because
I'm afraid it's going away it's not
going away okay just for that reason and
we did everything right yes last
Wednesday I said son of a it's
back
I said to cat there's no way that he
could if we if we do it on a Wednesday
right by the time he gets back Monday
there'll be so much in the news cycle
there's no way right that he would
resurrect us back impossible I served
deeply underestimated you
we both did and you brought him back and
he is I think it's a combination of both
I think it's the attention seeking and
he was getting a lot of attention and
then it was going to cost him his job
and then suddenly he wanted to keep his
check so then he could just put it all
the way and then he'll come back for a
little while and then it won't be too
long before there'll be a Halloween or
there'll be some kind of casual work day
that he will bring her back and then
everyone will be like oh he can't be
here and he'll be getting all his
attention again and somewhere in a
little cabin in New York you'll hear
yeah no no no
okay but that's me can I ask one last
question yes no so all we call all we
saw of Carrie Kayla whatever was you
know from the chest up obviously the the
delightful cannons but the calcium
cannons as the kids call them they they
weren't there but do you think he's got
like a giant
this is your last question this is the
last question it's fine to have giant
memories
exactly right that's the word is that's
just that's fine you know what I brought
that up on the first time we did this I
said what if it was a woman that walked
around with a giant Wang
so you know what maybe this was a more
important topic than any of you thought
okay
before we go a quick reminder I got some
special guest comedians for the next
stop on my book tour
Jamie lissau Jim Norton Joe Mackey Nick
de Paulo September 16th that's Reading
PA also be in Stamford Connecticut
that's a nice place and that'll be on
November 5th followed by Albany New York
and that's December 3rd so go to
gutfeld.com for Ticket info hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else